la question que tout le monde se pose ce
soir maintenant ce nuage de cendres et
ils potentiellement dangereux pour la
santé
et bien en réalité tout dépendra de la
manière dont il sera dispersé par les
vents pour l'heure les autorités
sanitaires se veulent rassurantes mais
reste vigilante florence bouki ya peu
encore marie dans ce nuage de cendres en
suspension à plusieurs kilomètres dessus
de nos têtes des microparticules
quelques millièmes de millimètre de
composés chimiques l'hydrogène sulfuré
dioxyde d'azoté des gaz toxiques
ceux là même que l'on respire en cas de
pollution atmosphérique liés par exemple
à la circulation automobile
mais pour le moment en france pas de
signes de pollution exceptionnel à
l'heure actuelle on ne dispose pas
d'informations nous permettant de dire
que les particules contenues dans le
nuage aurait des effets différents de
ceux des particules habituellement
rencontrées dans l'atmosphère urbaine
c'est quand les particules de cendre
retomberont que les autorités sanitaires
seront si certaines personnes plus
fragiles doivent prendre des précautions
qui est observée à court terme en lien
avec l'augmentation des niveaux de
pollution particulaire urbaine se sont
une augmentation des crises d'asthme une
augmentation des décompensations de
maladies cardiovasculaires un recours
aux services d'urgences ou à
l'hospitalisation au kazoo les
pneumologues prodiguerait alors les
mêmes conseils que lors des pics de
pollution habituel rester chez soi le
plus possible et si vous ne doit sortir
éviter de faire trop d'efforts physiques